et on commence donc par les élections en
allemagne avec les sociaux-démocrates de
la chose qui sont en tête selon les
premiers résultats officiels provisoires
un score historiquement bas pour l'accès
des où la famille politique d'angela
merkel pour en parler on va prendre tout
de suite la direction de berlin avec
notre grand reporter régis le sommier
[Musique]
elles régissent bonjour alors pas encore
de vainqueur définitif on le disait la
victoire irait timbres n'affichent holtz
avec une légère avance on se dirige donc
vers un gouvernement de coalition
oui c'est la tradition en allemagne de
toute façon sortait d'un gouvernement de
coalition avec cette fois ci à l'époque
la cd ou en tête et le spd en deuxième
et l'a finalement les résultats sont
inversés il pourrait en effet se faire
que ce soit une coalition al'inverse
donc c'est à dire que le spd serait
devant et la cd ou derrière et que ces
deux partis puissent s'entendre mais
c'est pas encore tout à fait sur la
lagune la question va être aujourd'hui
s'ouvre la période des négociations
les négociations qui vont durer
plusieurs semaines on parle même armin
laschet tu donc le candidat de la cdu ou
disait on aura le nom du chancelier
avant noël voyait donc ça va prendre un
petit moment et d'ailleurs ce qui est de
la particularité de l'allemagne c'est
que le battu d'hier donc le même armin
laschet tu lui aussi revendique
peut-être le fait d'être changées sur un
seul y est en tout cas ils n'écartent
pas l'hypothèse donc il ya il va y avoir
tout un tas de tractations ça va se
passer effectivement entre les
différents partis on sait déjà que les
verts vont se réunir pour savoir quel
avec qui ils vont dialoguer quand et
comment ils vont pouvoir installer leurs
lignes rouges parce que ces négociations
là sont se font sur les les programmes
au regard donc on discute et ça se fait
à l'allemande sait quelque chose un
exercice auquel en france on n'est pas
habitué puisque en général on a voilà le
lendemain des élections le résultat et
on sait qui est le vainqueur l'a
probablement olaf scholz havre a eu une
petite longueur d'avancé petit au niveau
du score le spd arrive simplement à un
point et demi devant la cedh et où ce
n'est pas beaucoup et c'est
historiquement bas pour les deux
d'ailleurs nous pas oublié qu'en 2005
quand un gala angela merkel est devenue
chancelière ces deux parties il a cumulé
à eux deux 70 % du corps électoral
aujourd'hui derrière il y a
le fpd là les verts
l'afd également qu'ils sont à plus de
10% donc l'électorat est très morcelé en
allemagne aujourd'hui et ce ne sont plus
ces deux partis qui ont régné
historiquement qui aujourd'hui peuvent
prendre peuvent naturellement s'imposer
donc il va y avoir tout un round de
négociations qui risquent de durer un
petit moment et on va écouter justement
les deux candidats qui sont en tête
écoutez
je me réjouis de voir tant de gens ici
et je me réjouis naturellement du
résultat du vote des citoyennes et
citoyens de ce pays
ils ont décidé que le parti
social-démocrate s'envolerait vers les
hauteurs et c'est un grand succès
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons déjà dire que nous ne
pouvons pas être satisfaits des
résultats
cela fait saison quand gay la merkel
s'est présenté comme chancelière ce
furent 16 bonne année pour l'allemagne
et je tiens donc avant tout à remercier
la chancelière angela merkel pour son
travail
alors régis quid d'anna lena barbeuk et
christian lindner les verts et les
libéraux ceux avec qui il va falloir
composer pour avoir un nom pour le
nouveau chancelier
et bien écoutez ce matin le journal
populaire bild fait sa une en les
appelant les faiseurs de roi donc voilà
ça va être eux qui vont être l'objet de
toutes les attentions alors on sait que
christian lindner et plus et plus proche
de la cd ou et naturellement je serais
tenté de dire 1 allez naber box serait
plus proche du spd mais tout ça va être
encore très il y a également les petits
partis vous avez l'afd mais personne ne
veut composer avec l'afd vous avez dit
linke donc extrême gauche qui a fait à
peu près 5% donc tout ça en fait ce
morcellement de de l'électorat qui s'est
traduit dans les urnes et bien
finalement fait que les petits partis
dont qui sont autour de 10% pourrait
décider de qui sera le prochain
chancelier en fonction de la coalition
dans laquelle il pourrait à partir de
laquelle il pourrait rentrer il ya
plusieurs types de coalition est là au
moins cinq ou six possibles de
combinaisons donc tout ça va être
extrêmement intéressant à suivre mais un
processus long et un processus qui dé
facto va faire que la chaîne la
chancelière en exercice donc en gala
merkel qui pensaient finalement être
partie où finalement avait décidé de ne
pas se représenter cette fois ci est
bien risque de rester au pouvoir pendant
encore quelques semaines voire plusieurs
mois c'est le paradoxe c'est la fin de
l'ère merkel mais c'est toujours elle
qui est au pouvoir merci beaucoup régis
pour toutes ces précisions régis le
sommier grand reporter pour rt france en
direct de berlin